You are listening to radio lab radio lab
from W N Y s t e
n n p. R on file. Could you, uh,
could you introduce yourself,
who you are? Uh, uh,
my name is Paul Auster. And
what do you do? What do I do?
I sit here and talk to
people like you and Nissa.
He's Paul Auster is one of the
most prolific writers we have.
I do the best I can,
but I went to see him because
anytime you open a Paul Auster book,
you notice that he is
noticing that in the world.
There are lots of strange repeats.
He calls them rhymes, rhyming
events. What is it? A rhyming event?
Well, arriving event would be
something. For example, uh,
the girlfriend I had when I was
very young, college, freshman,
sophomores had a piano in her apartment
and the f above middle seat was broken,
was the only note that
didn't work on the piano.
That summer we got together and
we went out to Maine Way, way out,
uh, in the wilds of Maine there Eastport.
And we were walking through a pretty
much an abandoned town and we walked into
what looked like an old
elks lodge or Moose Lodge.
And we walked up to the piano that was
sitting in the room and my girlfriend
could play very well. And
she tested out two piano.
One key was broken f above middle c.
So that to me is a rhyming events.
The F's always break. But
if that doesn't impress you and I, you
know, I'm going to give you another one.
This is a no, this is a
true story by the way.
The one you're about to hear and it's a
lopper. This is too weird. Well, it is,
um, the room. Um, so just, uh,
five pages in during the war,
m's father and hidden out from the Nazis
for several months in a Paris Shambo
the bun. Eventually he managed to escape.
Let's say Shambu did button a maid's room.
It's a small room on the top floor
of a Paris apartment building.
Shamba Dibon eventually
he managed to escape,
made his way to America
and began a new life.
Years past more than 20
years, m had been born.
I'd grown up and was now
going off to study in Paris.
[inaudible]
once there, he spent several difficult
weeks looking for a place to live.
Just when he was about to give up in
despair, he found a small Shambo to bun.
Immediately upon moving in, he
wrote a letter to his father
to tell them the good news, but we
could still later he received a reply.
Your address wrote Emma's father.
That is the same building
I hid out in during the war
and then went on to describe
the details of the room.
It turned out to be the same
room his son had rented.
Wait a second. So then father flees.
The Nazis stays in this room in
Paris, leaves 20 years go by.
The Sun happens to be in Paris, needs
a room. He finds a little vines.
So you're saying the same room,
the same exact same room. Yes.
Where his [inaudible] really happened.
You're not sorry. It didn't happen, Paul.
It happened to a friend of
Paul's. Wow. That is weird. Yeah.
And what do you make of that? Well, hi,
I'm not sure what to make of it except
that it gives you a funny sense that
sometimes in your life when something
happens and then weirdly it happens again,
that maybe that's intentional and maybe
like descriptives already been written
somehow. Exactly right. But you know,
it's interesting you see people, um,
there are people, it seems
to me who attract bad luck.
We know these people, we've
all known them. Absolutely.
And there are people who are
accident prone also. Yeah.
They're always breaking their
toe or breaking their leg. Yeah.
Well speaking of which, let me get,
uh, our producer Pat Walters in here.
Maybe before you do that you should
do, she just mentioned that this,
this is the, it's a radio lab. The pod.
We haven't done that yet. Oh, right.
This is radio lab. The podcast.
Right. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich and uh, our
subject is fate. Really? Yes.
We always seem to talk about the,
it's funny, I mean like we, we,
we'll have sometimes scientists on
the show when we talked to them about
whatever it is that they study,
but it always ends up being the case
of the real topic of conversation is
destiny. Like is it there?
Yeah, if it is, can you beat it?
[inaudible] we could be talking about
flowers and somehow this would come up and
said, we thought, uh, today we would, uh,
attack it a little more playfully and pat,
our producer got kind of obsessed with
something to do with fate and bad luck
and I don't really know about pat. Do
you want to just roll the tape? Yeah.
Just one second here. You live
in Arkansas, is that right?
That's correct. Yup. Yup.
I don't think you ever rode
renders down there, do you?
No, they're were, I think,
I don't think they've maybe gotten
into the far western part of the state.
Do you need me?
No. What that is jad hate that freaking
bird. Exactly. The road runner.
And who is this? This dude.
This is Mike Barrier, right?
I'm the author of a book
called Hollywood cartoons,
American animation in its golden age.
He's basically the guy you call if you
have like a big profound question about
looney tunes. Looney tunes.
Yeah. A few months ago,
Lulu and I started wondering like
in the Miller, our former producer,
why is road runner so good?
Because I am at least in the camp.
To answer your question, yeah.
But before we get to the answer,
I just want to give you a little
background on the cartoon. All right.
Go for it. It's 1949 when you're
at the movies with your wife,
you go in and you take a seat
and when the movie starts,
one of the very first things
you see is the cartoon.
And in the forties and
50s, most of these cartoons
chase cartoons. Tom and Jerry [inaudible]
Bank lady was a prime example.
[inaudible] problem was this
chase thing was a formula.
It was rigid and uh, it got a lot
of cartoonists kind of bored. Yeah.
So one day this kind of famous
cartoonist named Chuck Jones,
sitting around with his
buddy, Mike Martinez,
just talking about what the oddball
combinations of characters that could be
chasing each other.
Are they all to youth ball about having
an aardvark chasing a good new or
something like that.
But once again, you don't even know what
I can do is, but just cut to the chase.
Eventually they decided
let's make a cartoon about
coyote chasing a roadrunner
and when this cartoon came
out it was huge. It was a hit.
What does it mean for a cartoon
to be a hit? Like in those days,
cartoons usually only ran one
time, but this one was different.
Six months after it came out,
they started making another one,
which was almost completely unheard of.
Which brings us back to Lula's question.
Why is road runner so good?
Because I am at least in the camp that
it's way better than Tom and Jerry and
Mike says it's actually all about
the coyote.
He's an extraordinarily human animal
and not just like in the
facial expressions that he
made and the ways they look
at the camera. A lot,
but actually it kind of was about the
predicaments that he found himself in.
Meaning take for example, this
one really famous cartoon,
like always coyote has got a plan.
He has made a painting of the road
showing the road,
continuing over a casual,
put this painting right
at the edge of the cliff.
[inaudible] the roadrunner would
run through the painting, right?
He would take hold of him and
he was plunged into the chasm.
Roadrunner comes flying down the
highway and gets the painting,
but it doesn't fall. [inaudible]
instead of the road, water runs into
the painting as if it were the road.
We're actually continuing,
but then when the Coyote Trust [inaudible]
follow the road runner into the
painting, he runs through the painting
[inaudible]
he looks up at the camera and
he shrugged and he's like,
why did the bird gets run
into the painting and not me?
Gravity. Isn't this a
uniform in different force?
It's a malignant force that actually
comes in in an adult play is according to
how inconvenient it can be for the coyote.
That's interesting thing that the road
runner isn't his real opponent at all.
It's, it's the universe,
right? Oh yeah. No, he's chasing the
road and about the universes as opponent.
Absolutely.
And that's kind of what
makes the KOD seems so human.
He's in that situation that all of
us feel like we're in some times,
like the very laws of
physics are against us.
Yeah. Yeah. It's almost almost
a primitive way of thinking,
but [inaudible] I think all of us
lapsed endo does. You know that.
How can this happen?
The Universe is out to get me, like
you can't be human and not feel that way.
On the other hand, even though
the universe is screwing you,
at least it's noticing you.
It's got a flatter and get away.
It's totally flattering. Yeah, and this
makes sense. It's why the cartoon works.
Like on the one hand it
confirms our paranoia's and
then the other kind of plays
to our vanity
flattering. Is that really, I mean
when you said fluttering a second ago,
is that, is that really what it is? You
don't see it that way? I don't know.
I've never liked this cartoon
because he never wins.
It's like what's more flattering to live
in a world that actively screws you at
every turn or one that just doesn't
care about you like a Nietzschean void?
Um, I don't really know.
That's Kinda tough. I
go with the void. No.
What do you mean no really
ignored by the university? Yes.
The worst as opposed to being actively,
actively screwed by Russ. Yeah, sure.
Ignore me. You don't know
what you don't know. I,
I'll let me tell you this story.
I went to ABC News and I did
a story that went very well.
And then the next week I did a story
which went very badly and the head of the
place Roone Arledge called me into his
office. I think there's a Roone Arledge,
a legend in broadcasting. And then he
put his face right in front of my face,
his nose almost touching my nose
and said to me, I hated this.
I hated that. What's wrong
with you? And I'll say,
and instead of being sad and upset inside
my head, like Wiley, coyote himself,
I said, wow, he knows my
name. He watched my story.
But if rune had said that to you
every single day, he didn't do it.
Every single I know in cartoon form,
that's essentially what's happening. Yes.
[inaudible] yelling. But I, the reason
I like Wiley Coyote is because I,
I admire the guy.
He has no evidence at all that
anything good will ever happen to him.
And yet he wakes up every day with hope.
Hmm.
D
but some people really are what
we call losers. And uh, and it's,
it's fascinating to try to understand
why that person's always getting fired
from his job or,
or is unlucky in love all the time or
just can't seem to make it go of it,
but not now. Let's suppose
that unlike Mr Coyote,
you can't really be sure whether the
script that's been written for you,
if indeed there is one, is, um,
is going to get you deeper and deeper
into Doodoo or whether it's going to make
you a star or what.
Yeah. And when those moments
come along, you know,
when you feel like you're getting a peak
at the script maybe and then you think,
well we'll a is this real? And if it is,
what do you do? Yeah.
In fact, ah, Paul got to
one more story, which uh,
do you want to read it? Yeah,
why don't I read it cause I know
I know where it is. Okay. Yeah,
it's the last one in um, the red notebook.
It is a very strange story. Um,
my first novel was
inspired by a wrong number.
I was alone in my apartment in Brooklyn
one afternoon at my desk and trying to
work when the telephone
rang, if I'm not mistaken.
It was the spring of 1980.
I picked up the receiver and the man on
the other end as to if he was talking to
the Pinkerton Agency, I told him no, he
had dialed the wrong number and hung up.
Then I went back to work and
promptly forgot about the call.
The next afternoon the
telephone rang again.
It turned out to be the same person
asking the same question I had been asked
the day before, is this the Pinkerton
Agency again? I said, no, and again,
I hung up this time. However,
I started thinking about what would
have happened if I had said yes.
What if I had pretended to be a
detective from the Pinkerton Agency?
I wondered what if I had actually
taken on the case to tell the truth.
I felt that I had squandered
a rare opportunity, but
the men ever called again.
I told myself I would at least talk to
them a little bit and try to find out
what was going on. I waited for
the telephone to ring again,
but the third call never came.
After that wheels started turning
in my head, and little by little,
an entire world of
possibilities opened up to me.
When I sat down to write
city of glass a year later,
the wrong number had been transformed
into the crucial events of the book.
The mistake that sets the
whole story in motion.
A man named Quinn receives a phone call
from someone who wants to talk to Paul
Auster, the private
detective just as I did.
Quinn tells the caller is
dialed the wrong number.
That happens again on the next night
and again, Quinn hangs up unlike me.
However,
Quinn has given another chance when the
phone rings again on the third night,
he plays along with the caller and
takes on the case. Yes, he says,
I'm Paul Year,
and at that moment the madness begins
and not just for the character in the
story, but for Paul Auster himself
because when he wrote this book,
the city of glass,
it became a normal success and this
is now I'm writing in 1992 here.
I finished the book 10 years ago and
since then I've gone on to occupy myself
with other projects, other ideas,
other books, less than two months ago.
However, I learned that
books are never finished,
that it is possible for stories to go
on writing themselves without an author.
I was alone in my apartment
in Brooklyn. Then afternoon,
sitting at my desk and trying
to work when the telephone rang.
This was a different department from
the one I had in 1980 a different
department with a
different telephone number.
I picked up the receiver and the man on
the other end asked if he could speak to
Mr. Quinn clean. Remember is the name of
the man in the story who got the call.
You had a Spanish accent and I did
not recognize the voice for a moment.
I thought it might be one of my friends
trying to pull my leg. Mr. Quinn.
I said, is this some kind of joke
or what? No, it wasn't a joke.
The man wasn't dead earnest.
He had to talk to Mr. Quinn.
Would I please put him on
the line just to make sure.
Asked him to spell out the name.
The color's accent was quite thick and I
was hoping that he wanted to talk to Mr
Queen, but no such luck. Q. U. I. N. N.
The man answered.
I suddenly grew scared and for a moment
or two I couldn't get any words out of
my mouth. I'm sorry. I said it
last. There's no Mr. Quinn here.
You've dialed the wrong number. The
man apologize for disturbing me.
And then we both hung up. This
really happens like everything else.
I have sat down in this red
notebook. It is a true story.
So it really did it really. Then
I can get into you. Did you,
did you at the moment when he said,
uh, when you could have said, well,
this is Mr. Quinn. You could
have said that I was shaking.
I have to say I wasn't in F I was
not in full possession of myself.
It really disturbed me.
And to take a while to settle down and
you have this cause it's such a weird,
yes, it's inexplicable.
[inaudible]
but interesting because of them.
[inaudible] Paul Auster is the
author of the Red Notebook,
which these meetings are from the New
York trilogy, of course, which is the,
contains the city of glass, also man
in the dark, invisible sunset park.
He writes book after book after
book fourth. We should be off.
Thanks for listening. [inaudible] I
remembered Krulwich we'll see you later.
[inaudible].